Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my walking dead episode
6 video.
Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen it
yet.
It was mostly a Tara episode but they're just
laying tracks for what will become the season
finale episode 16 in the spring.
So there's some big stuff on the horizon.
So we finally confirm Oceanside a place that
we've heard about in the comics but haven't
really seen yet so they're moving this way
Oceanside doesn't really debut or actually
doesn't get mention till issue like 138 is
not like the save zone or the saviors compound
a place where you go spend a bunch of time
it is a place that we hear about is comprised
of people that fish for their food like they
say they have an unlimited supply of food
even without ambiguous end to you just have
to believe that there could come back at some
point because the have weapons.
They have unlimited food in surprise surprise.
Those just happened to be the things that
the save zone needs, so top 10 WTF and comic
book Easter eggs and just a really quick shoutout
just because YouTube doing some weird stuff
lately.
Make sure you enable alerts if you're subscribed
just so that you get all the videos because
supposedly Youtube's being weird but here
we go number 10 Tara and Heath have been scavenging
for the last two weeks and they haven't found
anything.
So this is where the timeline gets a little
messed up.
If you are confused because it seems like
Tara didn't know about anything that it happened
even to Denise because during the episode.
She says I have a girlfriend like to get back
to but we saw the knees die during season
six so already you, your kind of asking questions
in their jumping around.
So really the answer to that is that even
though we've had 6+ episodes this season so
far in a couple last season since Denise died
they haven't been moving in real time.
So it's only been about two weeks since Denise
died.
I think that your they did this because of
that last big moment you know number nine
which he actually gets back in Eugene just
breaks down.
It tells her what's been going on completely
taking the wind out of her sails.
Sorry to hear about the knees like the whole
episode like the tone was meant to be a little
more hopeful like Tara was all bubbly like
a we can work together we can make this happen
and then she gets back ends up that Denise
is dead with the saviors of done in just completely
breaks down, so number seven you know jumping
around in the timeline more Tara Heath make
it to the bridge.
Tara accidentally just yanks all those walkers
out of the sand.
It was a great reveals like one of the big
action set pieces of the episode Walker traps
are one of the most fun parts of walking that
summer better than others.
This one was pretty good but with the way
they broke that scene up in time across the
episode you just left to wonder how Tara wound
up on the beach.
But then you start to put the clues together
like oh she probably fell off the bridge and
got carried there, so number six the little
girl Rachel which is actually hilarious.
Reminds me of Carl from season three like
little baby Carl with the gun which is totally
ready to weigh someone in back she was making
that our motion.
Just as Cyndie stopped her like she stopped
her mid-stab before she could get Tara just
actually hilarious.
Throughout the entire episode in his Taras,
leaving just totally flips her off.
So number five though welcome to Oceanside.
So like I said is right out of the comics
but they haven't done a whole lot with it
in the comics yet.
So they're moving this way up on the TV show
is really just meant to broaden the universe
and lay tracks for what I think will become
all out war but the way they played in this
episode in the fact that there only two more
episodes before the end of the year made me
feel like it's gonna be a long time before
anybody gets there.
Should together and they marshal their forces
against the saviors swim at this community
of women who are pretty bad ass but super
nice and have unlimited food.
We will definitely be going back there in
the future but it just feels like it's not
can happen for a while the leader here in
the Tonya also not from the comics but wasn't
is just like the most chill interrogation
you've ever seen on The Walking Dead ever
like.
They asked her if she wants to go to the bathroom.
Do you want some fish to invite her to a sit
down dinner then asked her to join the community
and even offered to let her friend the talking
about Heath joint to if they can find him.
So these are like the nicest people ever visit
been any other group they would just punch
Tara in the face and just thrown her out on
the side of the street for the walkers to
take is and is just hilarious when you see
something like this and you think about what's
been happening to Daryl during his stay at
the saviors compound having to listen to that
song over and over and that is doing like
arts and crafts out here it Oceanside like
it's no big deal like of anything that almost
took me out of the episode like it just felt
way too nice for The Walking Dead.
But again it just feels like it's all set
up for that big payoff at the end when she
learns about all the crap that's happened,
I know some you are kind of disappointed that
she is an alpha, but that just means that
they could do whispers way way later.
So we can talk about them if they ever tease
him on the show.
It seems like there's some other group in
that weeks ahead trailer that Rick and Aaron
run into.
It has absolutely nothing to do with Oceanside.
So there's still a lot of other new characters
that they could crawl out of the comic book
woodwork number four though what happened
to all the dudes so they explained that the
saviors like it takes a while before they
both acknowledge that they've run afoul of
the saviors, but eventually the woman's like
oh the people that you went to kill the satellite
station.
There, the same people they killed all the
men everyone over a certain age and did you
catch what this woman says she dropped a bomb
on Tara like she made it sound like them attacking
that satellite station set off the chain of
events that cause the death of all of their
men and then is going to lead to some greater
conflict, but I think the problem there is
like you could blame the survivors and Rick
for making that decision to go against the
saviors, but they would've arrived at the
situation.
Eventually, no matter what.
So even if you want to lay blame technically
there in all the wrong I think it all just
depends on whether or not you believe the
true evil exists in the world do you think
that Negan is evil.
So just to give you an idea for the geography
a lot of people were confused about the timeline
for the Oceanside community.
The men were killed where they used to live
they bailed afterwords and found Oceanside
then erected that big barricade with the sand.
So the saviors have no idea where Oceanside
is.
That's why they're trying to keep it such
a secret.
But if you remember last week's episode, Stephen
August said that there was another mutual
group when he was talking to Gregory that
had been taken care of and wasn't an issue
anymore he might've been referring to the
conflict the saviors had with that Oceanside
group number three meet Cyndie she's not from
the comics but she could be in a mall gum
of characters they could be turning her into
like the magna character who's part of a different
community that is so many other groups of
people that they could introduce on the TV
show so we can talk about them if they actually
introduce them, but for the most part Cyndie
she's supposed to be this bad ass character
who is really hopeful you you don't choose
to be evil.
You just forget about who you are, so she's
meant to lay that seed inside Tara, but I
love Tara's answer to that I've seen evil
it exists, she's talking about the saviors,
but it's kind of funny because most of the
audience like me, you guys were thinking about
Negan when she's talking about evil people
really existing in the world, but she hasn't
met Negan yet she doesn't know anything about
that.
So when she's talking about evil existing
she was just talking about the saviors.
At that satellite station, but it does kind
of make you remember her experience with the
governor like the birth of the fist bump it
was so long ago that she debuted in that solo
Gov. episode it seems like it's been a long
time it was way back during season for, so
number two is Heath what happened to Heath.
There are tracks making it seem like he bailed
in the RV and got away but there's that little
key card with the peace symbols drawn on it,
which doesn't really refer to anything that
we've seen on the show so far.
It could belong to the saviors.
It could be he's trying to leave a clue or
something that he accidentally dropped but
Tara is just taking it is a sign the he's
got away.
So they played it super ambiguous just to
make you feel the anxiety of wondering what
happened to them.
Isn't it crazy that they didn't address it
when she got back to the save zone like she
just learns about the knees and is all bummed
out.
They don't address Heath at all like hate
that he's come back where's the RV, there's
no shots of it so that just some of the tricks
that The Walking Dead likes to play on you
just like making you wonder like what would
happen to see you guys can let me know in
the comments did Heath get back or was he
taken by the saviors or another group in that
key car belong to them, but my number one
was just like the conversation that you did
not hear her learning about all the crap that's
happened the last couple weeks or the last
six episodes really Glenn and Abraham were
killed Negan is imposing this crazy rule on
them.
Daryl is a prisoner every once in shambles
the saviors have already taken most of our
supplies.
So we have nothing but it did close the loop
on like this really hopeful arc like it deftly
balance that out.
So let me know what was your favorite moment
from the episode and how long do you think
it's gonna be before we see the Oceanside
people again like I feel like Cyndie has to
come back they set her up as such a bad ass
character you can't just never bring her back.
So this can be some huge war in the season
finale I feel like she is going to be a part
of it the real MVP of the episode though is
Rachel she's probably one of the best new
characters in this.
I hope they bring her back.
Even though I'm not expecting her to be like
a really huge character the life expectancy
of children on The Walking Dead is usually
pretty short unless they're willing to kill
she seems like more of a Carl type character
so maybe they'll keep her around what can
happen next is I'll post my Westworld video
then I'll post the walking dead trailer video
and there is a new round of the walking dead
giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video and just
because.
YouTube is being really weird.
Make sure you turn alerts on make sure that
little bell is grayed out.
So those and some Rick and Morty is coming
down the pipeline too later this week maybe
on Tuesday I'm going to be doing Rick and
Morty videos but I'll explain how that's going
to work when I post that first video while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for the craziest game of thrones theories
you've ever heard and you can click here to
start getting ready for the big Flash DC 4
night crossover this week so let's fist bump
see you guys tonight!